Bracey, il va pénétrer dans les
villes civilisées du soir, tu regardes le commandement directement
en face quand tu lui parles, ce
n'est pas confortable, ce n'est pas supposé
qu'il y a une situation grave, madame.  O'Dwyer a
été enlevée, elle est tout pour moi et
ces sauvages de Dieu sont ce qu'ils sont
différents ou chaque seconde si nous avons encore un
vous savez, je n'ai pas de nom
combien d'entre eux vous pensez qu'il y a peu
importe que vous ayez  aucune chance d'en avoir un
certain nombre Je viens avec vous non non
j'ai besoin de vous ici et de cette façon pour les sauvegardes
pour aider une urgence à ne pas rester en arrière
J'arrive nous faisons un
voyage de cinq jours en trois jours à cheval  et
dormir le strict minimum même si c'est à l'
ouest d'ici pas de remorque à bétail quoi que ce soit d'
autre va dans cette direction nos chevaux
meurent avant d'y arriver nous allons en
territoire hostile faibles et brumeux d'
épuisement
nous ne sauverons personne n'ayez pas peur
je suis un  ami tu es
tu n'avais pas de raison si tu veux remettre en question
ma morale fais le plus tard bénis nous O Seigneur
et ces tes dons que nous sommes sur le point
de recevoir